so no one decides what their why is your
why is inside you and if you choose to
go in the Journey of Discovery
um and you're able to put that Y into
words so the thing that drives your gut
like there's no part of your stomach
that makes decisions right you know your
gut feeling comes from somewhere uh and
it is this deep-seated purpose cause or
belief that we all have because we're
all products of our upbringing and you
are who you are and
um and so for me it wasn't a question of
um
uh deciding on it but it was discovering
it and not uncommon
you can go through a process of
discovery because you just decide you
want to
um or you can very often struggle uh
reveals your why to you
um I think that's probably very much
your case as well you know you had to
hit the bottom before you realized who
you were I had to face uh what I thought
was bankruptcy to face collapse I had to
face
um humiliation
um uh to to discover what my cause was
and and I think you probably share this
as well which is I couldn't have done
that alone
and it it took a friend coming to me in
this very dark place that I spent all of
my energy pretending that I was happy
more successful and More in control than
I really felt
um uh and lying hiding and faking is
exhausting
um and it it took a friend to say
something's not right even my I was so
good at it even my family didn't
recognize it and but this friend did and
I came clean and all of the energy went
into that was going into line hiding and
faking went into
rediscovering passion
um and it wasn't the discovering of my
why that sent me on the path it was the
discovering of my why and then wanting
desperately to share with my friends
because I love my friends and I want
them to have what I found
and they started making Crazy Life
Changes and making these huge decisions
with total confidence
and they would invite me to their homes
to share with their friends and I would
literally stand in someone's living room
talking about this thing called the Y
and that's what ignite ignited the spark
that I realized that I I had something
to give
um and you discover you discover service
I mean this is what a life of service
means which is
um you know the reason you know people
keep talking about or we're told you
have a gift you know well the very
definition of a gift is it's supposed to
be given and I think that if you have a
gift and you're not sharing it I think
you're just selfish